FROM CHILDREN AND FACT FROM
FICTION.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE" ."
THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN HAMMERING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, MAKING
SCURRILOUS CHARGES THAT HIS
DRACONIAN IMMIGRATION POLICIES
ARE SEPARATING FAMILIES AND
LOSING TRACK OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
>> THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
THREATENING TO SEPARATE MORE
PARENTS AND KIDS AT THE BORDER
SCREAMING AND CRYING PLEASE
DON’T LET ME BE TAKEN AWAY.
>> CALLS ABOUT 7600 OF THOSE
CHILDREN AND THEY COULDN’T FIND
1500 OF THEM.
>> DONALD TRUMP REALLY IS
OBSESSED WITH PERHAPS THE MOST
SICK PART OF THE ENTIRE POLICY,
SEPARATING FAMILIES FROM EACH
OTHER.
>> Laura: PREDICTABLY,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ALSO
WEIGHED IN WITH A PIECE TITLED
TO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
SEPARATE IMMIGRANT CHILDREN FROM
PARENTS AND LOSE THEM?
WELL, AS YOU WILL SEE, THIS IS
NOT REPORTING.
IT’S CALLED TRYING TO CREATE A
NARRATIVE REGARDLESS OF THE
ACTUAL FACTS TO MANIPULATE
READERS’ EMOTIONS AND ULTIMATELY
FORCE A CHANGE IN POLICY.
NEVER ONE TO FORGO A RIDE ON THE
BANDWAGON, CNN’S POSS GOLD
TWEETED THIS.
A PICTURE OF IMMIGRANT CHILDREN
AND WHAT APPEARED TO BE CAGES
WITH THE CAPTION "FIRST PHOTOS
OF SEPARATED MIGRANT CHILDREN OF
HOLDING FACILITY.
THE INFERENCE OF COURSE BEING
THAT TRUMP HIMSELF WAS CONFINING
HIM AS IMMIGRANT CHILDREN RIPPED
FROM THEIR MOTHER’S ARMS INTO
WIRE CAGES.
THE SAME PICTURE WAS SHARED BY
FORMER OBAMA OFFICIALS LIKE JOHN
FAVREAU AND THE USUAL
TRUMP-HATING ACTIVISTS SUCH AS
WOMEN MARCH BOARD MEMBER LINDA.
BUT THERE’S ONLY ONE PROBLEM
WITH THIS PHOTO.
IT’S FROM 2014.
WHEN THE SAINTLY BARACK OBAMA
AND THE COMPASSIONATE ONES WERE
ALL IN CHARGE.
AT THE TIME, THE LEFT-WING MEDIA
DID NOT CONSIDER DETAINING
ILLEGALS WORTH COVERING.
BUT NOW THAT TRUMP IS TRYING TO
ENFORCE OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS, HE
SUDDENLY JUST A HEARTLESS THUG.
GOLD HAD TO RETRACTOR TWEET BUT
SHE DIDN’T APOLOGIZE RATING
"DELETED PREVIOUS TWEET BECAUSE
GAVE IT IMPRESSION OF RECENT
PHOTO."
THEY ARE FROM 2014.
IT GAVE THE IMPRESSION BECAUSE
YOU WROTE THAT THEY WERE FIRST
PHOTOS OF MIGRANT KIDS IN
DETENTION.
IT USUALLY DOESN’T LABEL
SOMETHING FIRST PHOTOS WHEN THEY
ARE FOUR YEARS OLD.
WE ARE STILL WAITING FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TO
APOLOGIZE FOR ITS OUTRAGEOUS
HEADLINE.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THE TIMES
COULD HAVE ANSWERED THEIR OWN
QUESTION BY READING FURTHER DOWN
IN THEIR OWN PEACE.
DID THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
SEPARATE IMMIGRANT CHILDREN FROM
PARENTS AND LOSE THEM?
NO, THEY CLEARLY DIDN’T BECAUSE
THE TIMES WRITES THAT THOSE
CHILDREN HAD ARRIVED ALONE AT
THE SOUTHWEST BORDER WITHOUT
THEIR PARENTS.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
HOW CAN YOU SEPARATE ILLEGAL
ALIEN CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS WHEN THE PARENTS SENT
THEM HERE ALONE?
THERE IS A GLARING LOOPHOLE IN
THE IMMIGRATION LAW THAT FORBIDS
DEPORTING UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
FROM CENTRAL AMERICA,
NONCONTIGUOUS COUNTRIES.
THE ILLEGALS KNOW THIS SO THEY
ABUSE THE SYSTEM AND I WOULD
ARGUE ENDANGER THEIR CHILDREN IN
THE PROCESS.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
UNACCOMPANIED ILLEGAL MINOR --
BUT REMEMBER HE OR SHE COULD BE
16, 17 OR ONE DAY FROM HIS OR
HER 18TH BIRTHDAY, BY THE WAY,
CROSSES THE BORDER ILLEGALLY?
THE UNITED STATES THEN THROWS
THEM INTO WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY A
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
ACCORDING TO STEVE WEGNER, AND
HHS OFFICIAL, THE 10,000
CHILDREN AND TEENS IN CUSTODY
COST THE TAXPAYERS OVER
$1 BILLION ANNUALLY.
OTHERS ARE SENT TO SPONSORS.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
GOVERNMENT FINDS THE KIDS
SPONSORS OR FAMILY MEMBERS IN
THE UNITED STATES WHOM THEY CAN
GO LIVE WITH AS THEIR CASE
PROCEEDS, OR BETTER PUT, AS IT
DRAGS ON FOR YEARS WHILE OF
COURSE IF YOU SHOW UP FOR THEIR
DEPORTATION OR IMMIGRATION
HEARING.
SO AT THE START OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION LOST IMMIGRANT
KIDS, THEY DIDN’T LOSE ANYBODY.
WHEN HHS TRIED TO CHECK UP ON
THESE KIDS WITH THEIR SPONSORS,
AT TIMES, ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES THEMSELVES CARING FOR
THE CHILDREN, 1475 FAILED TO
TAKE THE CALLS OR EVEN RESPOND
TO THE GOVERNMENT AT ALL.
SO THE IMMIGRANT KIDS AREN’T
LOST.
THEIR SPONSORS JUST HAVEN’T
CONNECTED WITH THE HHS, OR MADE
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE.
BUT THE MEDIA WANT TO
MISCONSTRUE THAT AS LOSING A
KID, OKAY.
LET’S DO THAT FOR A MOMENT.
HYPOTHETICALLY LET’S JUST SAY
THAT THAT’S CORRECT.
OBAMA LOST NEARLY THREE TIMES
THE NUMBER OF KIDS,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTING A
2016 INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
SHOW THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WAS ABLE TO REACH ONLY 84% OF
CHILDREN IT HAD PLACED LEAVING
4,159 UNDERCOUNTED
4,159 UNACCOUNTED FOR.
CORRECT ME IF I’M WRONG, I DON’T
REMEMBER ANY MEDIA LASHING OUT
AT OBAMA FOR LOSING KIDS OR
SEPARATING THEM FROM THEIR
FAMILIES.
IN FACT, OBAMA AND HIS HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY TRY TO A FEW
TIMES TRIED TO ADOPT A HARD-LINE
ON THE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS WHEN
THERE WAS A HUGE RUSH AT THE
BORDER AS YOU WILL RECALL BACK
IN 2014.
>> OUR DIRECT MESSAGE TO THE
FAMILIES IN CENTRAL AMERICA, DO
NOT SEND YOUR CHILDREN TO THE
BORDERS.
IF THEY DO MAKE IT THEY WILL GET
SENT BACK.
>> OUR MESSAGE, TO THOSE WHO ARE
COMING HERE ILLEGALLY, TO THOSE
WHO ARE CONTEMPLATING COMING
HERE ILLEGALLY INTO SOUTH TEXAS,
IS WE WILL SEND YOU BACK.
>> Laura: ONE PROBLEM, THEY
COULDN’T BE SENT HOME.
THEY COULDN’T BE DEPORTED
BECAUSE OF THE INSANE
IMMIGRATION LAWS WE CURRENTLY
HAVE IN PLACE.
BY THE WAY, WHICH IS WHY TRUMP
IS RIGHT, THE LAW HAS TO CHANGE,
CONGRESS MUST ACT.
NOT ONLY TO END THIS
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR LOOPHOLE,
BUT THE CATCH AND RELEASE
PROGRAM AS WELL AS CHAIN
IT.
SO IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY THIS
ANTI-TRUMP MEDIA NARRATIVE IS
BEING ADVANCED AT THIS TIME.
WHY?
IT’S BECAUSE TRUMP IS CLOSE TO
MAKING GOOD ON HIS PROMISE TO
TRANSFORM OUR IMMIGRATION LAWS
FOR THE BETTER.
EVEN THE LEFT REALIZES THIS
ISSUE IS A WINNER FOR
REPUBLICANS.
TOM FRIEDMAN, WHO IS A FAVORITE
OF THE GLOBAL ELITE, OBVIOUSLY
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST-SELLING
AUTHOR.
EVEN HE THIS MORNING WAS
RECOGNIZING THIS ISSUE AS A
VULNERABILITY FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> I THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL
THINGS THAT ARE TRUE THAT
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO WRESTLE WITH.
WE CANNOT TAKE EVERY IMMIGRANT
IN A WORLD THAT IS SPLITTING
BETWEEN A WORLD OF ORDER AND
DISORDER.
>> Laura: WOW.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO GO WOBBLY
ON IMMIGRATION OR EMBRACE SOME
TYPE OF BLANKET AMNESTY.
THERE IS ONE POINT THAT THE LEFT
AND THE RIGHT SHOULD BE ABLE TO
AGREE ON, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
RECENT MEDIA INDIGNATION.
WE ALL WANT CHILDREN TO BE
TOGETHER, UNIFIED WITH THEIR
PARENTS.
SO LET’S MAKE THAT HAPPEN IN THE
COUNTRY OF THEIR ORIGIN.
IT IS IMMORAL TO ALLOW LAWS ON
THE BOOKS THAT INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN
ALONE INTO A FOREIGN COUNTRY OR
TO FRANKLY MAKE A DANGEROUS TRIP
WITH THEIR PARENTS.
AND UNTIL THOSE LAWS CHANGE,
IMMIGRANT CHILDREN WILL CONTINUE
TO BE SEPARATED FROM THEIR